Let's talk about
exocytosis,
the process in which the cell
releases large molecules,
which can be used in other parts of the body.
From other cells or as a part
of the extracellular matrix.
To understand how this process is going,
we need to reverse endocytosis
and produce
proteins
in the endoplasmic network,
this will be a classic example of exocytosis.
These proteins will be released in
own secretory vesicles (vesicles),
which will then merge with the Goldie apparatus.
There they will be processed further.
Processed in the Goldie apparatus,
right here.
They will then separate from
the Golgi apparatus in new secretory bubbles,
who will go
to the cell membrane,
plasma membrane.
The membranes of these bubbles
will merge with the cellular
membrane
and thus will separate
your content.
This is classical exocytosis.
There are other cases,
in which
the bubble may partially merge, separate its contents
and to go back,
this method of exocytosis is called
kiss-and-run.
But with the classic method the bubble is
merges with the membrane.
Lets look
this cell membrane,
with which the membrane of the bubble has merged.
The cell membrane may look like this.
If the bubble -
I will make the membrane of the vesicle orange.
If the bubble membrane is orange,
now it merges with the cell membrane
and has released its contents.
She has separated the protein,
which will be used
somewhere else in the body.
I want to make it clear,
this membrane -
I talk about it often in
many other videos -
Although I have painted the membrane as a single line
here,
it consists of a double phospholipid layer.
If we look at it closely,
it will look like this.
It is a phospholipid double layer.
These are some of the phospholipids,
which were part of the original
cell membrane,
but in the box
there are also phospholipids from
the secretory bubble,
in which was the protein.
That was part of the secretory bubble, which
stored the protein.
I want to pay close attention
of these lines,
which I paint,
they are double layers of phospholipids.
All these lines,
these membranes you see,
they are all double layers of phospholipids.
I pay attention to this to make sure,
that you imagine things right.
This is exocytosis.
It is interesting that
when you learn about it for the first time,
you see her depicted on charts here,
and you say to yourself,
"Okay, obviously these bubbles
with these membranes
just sail at random
and eventually reach the cell membrane,
with which they merge
and release their content. "
But actually the process is not so chaotic.
Indeed, vesicles are on rails,
stand on rails.
Remember the cytoskeleton,
which is not drawn often enough,
perhaps because it makes the drawings
very confused.
But when we think of a cage,
it has all these structures.
Structures such as
microtubules, microfibers,
intermedia filaments.
All of them
not just give the structure of the cell,
but can be used for transport.
And the vesicles
can "ride"
of these structures.
We can have
motor proteins that use ATP,
to transport the bubble
and its contents.
This mode of transport is like
factory,
which pushes the bubbles to the membrane,
to separate their content.
The process is remarkable.
I always say the cells
are universes on their own.
They're not just some spots,
have all these structures,
all these proteins,
which are incredibly small, but
perform very complex processes.
What I showed you is
classical exocytosis.
You will meet her when the proteins or lipids
are produced in the cage
and must be separated.
Exocytosis is also used
in the neurons.
When chemical signals are
transmit from one neuron to another,
we have neurotransmitter exocytosis,
which trigger the next neuron.
These are many, very important processes.
Our bodies would not function properly
or would not function at all
if we had no exocytosis.